[Music]
we have chapter two lexes lexicon and
vocabulary organizing lexis war is a
lexicon a lexicon is a set of inventory
of all the lexemes in a language Lexus
is the analytical level of a language
that deals with vocabulary as opposed to
morphology or syntax it's also defined
as a complete group of all words in a
language languages with sufficiently
productive morphology for instance may
have an infinite set of words or Lexus
but still have a finite lexicon or like
seams that can be listed in a dictionary
vocabulary on the other hand refers to a
subset of words in a language that are
used in a particular context or known to
a particular person
how can Lexus be organized we have
alphabetical listing head words with an
entry following each word or item items
are all favit eyes or placed in
alphabetical order this is useful
because it is largely an ambiguous and
readers can find items easily we have a
word listing which which in parts of
speech such as nouns pronouns adjectives
verbs adverbs and prepositions etc are
listed in the dictionary apart from
getting information about use we need to
be aware of world class for spelling it
for instance to distinguish nouns and
verbs
you